thanks for joining us again on the
pretty intense podcast today on the show
is Vienna Farren she is a licensed
marriage and family therapist she has a
new book out called the origins of you
immediate disclosure she was my
therapist for about a year and a half we
actually started the episode with me
going into the four most impactful
things that I learned while working with
her we went into depth into what those
are what they mean how to access them
the thing about doing therapy and doing
work and work on yourself is knowing how
to even know to do it it's like the
first thing that we talk about is the
Observer like how to access the Observer
how do you even do that when you get
caught in a moment like how do you how
do you stop it before you just end up in
your pattern or in your trigger there's
so many good like access points that
Vienna gives as to how to get to those
places so that we can truly just
experience more joy more more peace in
our lives I mean isn't that the point
and so you know it comes through some
pain it comes through some change uh and
it comes through facing things and
sitting in the fire but I promise you
I'm product of not work that's done as
she states and as I know it's never done
but there are levels to it and um I love
the work and I love being more happy and
more joyful and having maybe a more
accurate perspective from time to time
and not being caught in my patterns or
as she says the origins of you meaning
your patterns and your wounds that get
developed when you're a kid so anyway
great great episode please enjoy this
with Vienna hit subscribe and the bell
for notifications I'm super grateful for
you here and please let me know what you
think in the comments and share sort of
your experiences and maybe some Pathways
to growth that have really worked for
you it's pretty like this is a pretty
book yeah I mean that's not always easy
to do because like what not and it's
like it's very different like I'm a very
neutrally person it does it it's like
it's a book that someone who doesn't
know me might pick up because it catches
their eye I actually think that the
colors make it happy and hopeful too
like there's an there's a there's sort
of an underlying energy to the colors
being like the origins of you which the
truth is is we're here to talk about the
shitty ones right but it's like here but
they're in green and blue and yellow and
red and pink yeah and then they opened
up the book and they're like uh oh
you got a great chance because this is
these are things that the world needs
um and you're an incredible therapist uh
truth be told uh to the world uh Vienna
has been my therapist uh you were my
therapist for like a year and a half so
um we have a lot of we know a lot about
well you know a lot about me I know I
know a lot about you but you know a lot
about me yeah
um and so I can attest to the fact that
you know you're incredible and
um
okay I think we're gonna start I was
gonna ask you about the book but maybe
since I've just said that I'll do what I
wanted to do is I went back to my notes
from when we worked together and I
because there was so many gems like
especially early on when I was so
needing it like there were just some
huge like hits that I was like Wow and
that was kind of the magic of working
together is that you there was always
just like a statement at the end of each
session that was like oh that's it
um so you really distill things down
very well there was four things that I
pulled from the notes that I thought
were truly truly truly the most
transformative things for me in my life
that I still used to today so I thought
we'd go through them and you could
explain them and explain like what it
means and how to access it and and just
sort of the the origins of these uh of
these thoughts
um so I thought that would be I thought
that that's cool I love this okay yeah
so the first one is uh the Observer like
being able to access the Observer and to
pause and have that moment so explain to
people what is the Observer and how the
hell do we get there yeah I love the
Observer it's you know I think the
Observer actually bursts from
the witnessing component to what I talk
about in the book so so first like The
Observer to to almost step out of being
in this moment this experience this
conflict that you're having this big
reaction that you're experiencing and
it's in that pause um it's been
attributed to to Victor Frankel
um that that space between you know
stimulus and response right and so it's
in this space right where we can where
if we can just take the beat right pause
for a moment and become the Observer of
what's happening in my inner world right
now right what's going on because in
that space we start to be able to ask
ourselves the questions like what's
familiar about this moment you know what
what what origin wound is this rubbing
up against I always say right that like
as adults it's very uncommon for us to
have a first experience in terms of
emotion
it's not uncommon to have a first
experience of you know content and
context something that's happening in
our lives but when it rubs up against
ooh I'm starting to question my
worthiness I'm starting to question my
belonging I'm starting to question
whether I feel like a priority in
somebody's life I'm starting to question
whether I can trust this person this
situation or I'm starting to to question
whether or not I feel safe in this
Dynamic right it's like those things
which are the origin wounds I talk about
in in the book right it's like that's
what's familiar and so when we can
become the observer in these moments
where there's a big reactivity there's a
pattern that I keep finding myself in
and I need to become
curious and you know get get into the
inquiry of what's actually being
presented here we're going to find
something something that links to
something else that is unresolved about
our past not really about the thing
happening it's about the thing inside
you yeah I mean it's like you've heard
this before right like therapists around
the world are like it's not about the
toilet seat it's not about the towel on
the bed it's not about third yeah right
like all of these things which sure
objectively sometimes are quite annoying
sometimes we're like no no I promise
it's about the towel on the bed I'm like
listen I get it right and there is also
something additional that's playing out
here those are kind of the systemic the
systemic sort of reactions yes to the
origin like this is the hard part I
think because it's like all in theory
it's great access the Observer have a
pause but we aren't freaking Buddhas
right and we're not on a mountain we've
got stimulus happening all the time
what is some ways that we can Orient
ourselves
differently in the world on a macro
level that gives us the ability to have
a pause because it's not not knowing
that a pause is good everybody knows a
pause is good problem is you can't it's
it's very hard when you get the stimulus
or you get the trigger so like what is
it that comes first before you can
actually become an observer
what I would say is to practice when
you're not in the stimulus right so a
lot of times we try to practice when you
know that we're on stage and it's like
nope can't do it already activated you
pissed off in the loop ready to go and
like we're out right and so so much of
the inquiry and the Curiosity it's
really helpful when we're doing that
work when we're feeling grounded when
we're just in a place of questioning and
wanting to get to know these parts of
ourselves better when we're not actually
in that hot seat you're right when we're
when we're in it and we don't have the
you know we're trying to practice the
tools but the tools are out the window
before we even know it it can feel like
it's it's a pointless uh path to go down
the second thing that I would say though
is one of the things that helped me so
much personally was that the more that I
witnessed and grieved my own pain the
less likely I would need to hook into
the pattern or The Loop when it when it
was trying to play itself out even when
the stimulus was happening so what I
mean by that is
when I when you can identify what the
origin wound is right so again whether
that's I don't feel worthy I don't feel
deserving I don't feel good enough
whether it's I don't feel like I fit in
I don't have a sense of belonging I
don't feel like a priority to my partner
et cetera Etc right when we can actually
see like oh here's the thing that
activates me and then if I connect my
dots and I travel backwards a bit I'm
gonna probably find that that lived
somewhere else too right maybe I didn't
feel like a priority with a parent
um maybe I didn't feel like a priority
with a sibling right maybe that was
something that was deeply impactful for
me and so when we go back into this
origin space and we begin to actually
process and feel and connect and witness
the pain of that because usually those
origin wounds they do cut deep right
they're not just like a brush you know
it's like no these are things that
actually change the trajectory of Our
Lives of our worlds of our beliefs about
ourself ourselves and other people and
life at large right these are
significant moments that set the stage
for us and so when we go back to those
moments and we actually witness the
little Vienna in this case right who
had you know who was The Observer and
the witnesser of a tremendous amount of
conflict and gaslighting and
manipulation and paranoia and abuse as a
little girl uh through through my
parents divorce right like oh and I get
to witness her and what it was like for
this little human who had no other
siblings who didn't have any other
adults around to help her process this
right then I start to connect with you
know the part of me that that didn't
feel emotionally safe right where I felt
like they had lost focus of what my
emotional needs were at that time
because you know they were so distracted
by their own pain and their own
suffering right right and so when you
can start to connect to that to grieve
alongside of it I always say like when
in doubt grieve more you know it's like
when stuck grieve more like anything
grieve more you know it's like yeah our
experiences need our grief and my
personal experience with this is that
the more time that I spent with little
me you know the more time I spent
connecting to that pain the more time I
spent
um witnessing what that was like for
little me
the less I needed to engage in the
dysfunction present day
because I was tending to myself
elsewhere so instead of trying to get
whomever right whether it's a parent or
someone else to witness or see or
acknowledge me in this current moment
right there was almost like a
like a emotional bank account of I've
done I'm doing the witnessing I've done
the witnessing I have a great partner
who sees me hears me understand it is
this true like a comment that comes
through and like repeated like when you
see the little little girl or little boy
within you it's the innocence and the
Perfection and you see you have it's
it's something separate from you but
it's still treating it like it's
separate from you is still treating you
and so you'd never treat your kid like
that you'd never say you don't belong
you'd never say you're not worthy so it
almost like accesses the is this really
true kind of a question yeah right and
it and it disrupts that because that's
what we're talking about with this you
know going back to your original
question around you know how sure the
observer in theory is great but in
practice and I think it's when you are
tending to yourself or you invite in
humans in your life who tend to you well
whether friendship partnership Etc right
then you are less likely and less in
need of engaging in the dance that you
know is not going to go very well with a
particular person right like you don't
need to hook into that dysfunctional
pattern right this Loop
um and tending to yourself or having
other humans who can witness intend I
say it in the book like there's this
moment
um I was talking to a family member or
the conversation was going in the same
way that it always goes it was on
speakerphone at the time my husband was
in the room and after we hung up he said
I get it you know I I in so many words
he was validating an experience that I
had you know complained about
um for some time I remember it was such
a simple but really profound moment for
me because I realized that I didn't need
the person who
put the wound there in the first place
to be the person who witnessed my pain
that's nice if we can get it certainly
of course but I remember this deeply
profound moment of like it doesn't have
to be that person yeah
right and
again like in theory might sound like
yeah of course right but I think so many
of us especially in family Dynamics
family systems like there's this wish
there's this deep want and need right
that a parent might be able to
acknowledge and
you know
just acknowledge your pain right or just
acknowledge your experience or just take
ownership for something that you really
want them to own and so sometimes we get
so caught up in it I've had so many
conversations with people it's like well
maybe if I say it this way or maybe if I
write a letter if maybe I use this tone
or maybe yeah
number two that was literally the most
transformative thing that you said to me
do you know what it was can you remember
no I don't know what it was well you
talked to hours hours and hours
thousands of people
um I don't expect you to but it's
probably because it's so second nature
to you but it's when you told me that
day after I was complaining about all
the things and Dad and parents and and
you were like nobody holds the keys and
I was like
Bach because I I think the first thing I
said was I was like whoa and I started
crying and I was like that's really
heavy because that means that
it's all on me like it's I don't know if
I said it's my fault but I'm like
essentially alone and figuring that out
and you're like no you're not you have
me you have people you don't have to do
it alone but it is up to you it's like I
say now it's like your wounds are not
your fault but they are your
responsibility to heal and so when you
reminded me or at least like got it
through to me there was like the
freaking crack in the door was there and
you're like nobody holds the keys
because no matter what anyone said it
just didn't work right and so it totally
flipped the script which helps me with
the Observer because I now know that
whenever something is happening all I do
is say what's my part in this
because I know that it's my perception
of a re of a of a situation that is
dictating the way that I feel so I'm
like what is my part yeah so nobody
wants the keys so so yeah powerful yeah
I love hearing your words your words I
love hearing it because it's so funny
when you're like oh my gosh I said that
you know
so many people so many therapists are
like I don't remember all the things
that I said or you don't always know the
things that are gonna land or resonate
so deeply but I I do recall
um I do recall this and I think there's
that diff you're psychic I just want to
say that you know you might not know you
probably know but that was very apparent
to me very early on as you're extremely
intuitive and I can feel and see and
know when you're in those spaces and um
it's obviously super helpful that you
are yeah you're like oh I'm listening to
this my ears are open right now there's
a no one holds the keys right I think so
many of us will get into a place where
we start to Outsource there's this
bargaining this negotiation that starts
to happen once so-and-so does this then
I will feel worthy
happens then this right all of these if
then statements
they start to enter in and we get
distracted by them if only if only what
that doesn't resolve
your origin pain right like that's a
Band-Aid it might feel nice right you
partner with someone who like for the
first many weeks is making sure all the
dates are happening and they're
following through and you're like I'm a
priority right you're like well you know
maybe right in these moments there's
like a nice experience that feels good
fine sure but that thing is not actually
tending to the wound right to choose
someone eventually right who does
prioritize you if you have a
prioritization wound for example that's
going to be deeply healing right it's
going to be deeply healing but when we
go to this space right when we bypass it
right when we try to bypass the wound
and just pick the human who's somehow
going to resolve what is deep inside of
us for us right that can't last that way
and when I describe like resolving our
wounds we all know that this is a
forever practice right we ebb and flow
through it sometimes there is much less
of a charge sometimes there's a little
bit more of a charge because that's how
grief works right every time we are
brought back into contact with something
right like yeah there might be a bit of
a feeling there and so our goal is not
to get to a place of being unaffected by
everything but this idea of like no one
out no one holds the keys right no one
else outside of you is going to do
something for you that is going to
resolve what needs to be felt and
experienced and witnessed by you at
least first can other people support in
that absolutely right I'm a big believer
that it fits relationships that wound it
requires relationships to help us heal
right
um and and I believe that as individuals
we can only take ourselves so far far
because it's in theory it can't be in
practice without relationships so again
in theory ooh this is what I'll say when
this person does X you know like that
that's nice but until you are in those
moments where the wounds are activated
again and you're face to face with the
beliefs about yourself that you've been
trying to navigate and shift and pause
with right like it's in those
relationships where we have to put
you know pedal to the metal yeah I think
it's a good opportunity to actually talk
a little bit about boundaries because
that almost feels like I'm going to get
to the next point which kind of has to
do with it but before we do
um boundaries like because that's what
feels like the natural progression when
you take it into your own when take it
onto yourself and when you take it into
your own hands and you don't let you
don't need anyone else to fix the
situation is that it's actually because
you're tending to the inner child which
kind of starts with The Observer by
going what do you need you now have a
relationship with yourself and what you
need and when you know what you need
that you're not relying on someone else
to give it to you so explain boundaries
because this is something that I totally
thought was something for someone else
like oh don't do that to me I never
thought they were basically boundaries
were from me meaning like this is how
you treat me this is what I'm willing to
put up with and what I'm not willing to
put up with and then I leave I don't
tell you to change I go because these
are my boundaries for me like how we
teach other people how to treat us right
and like what's allowed and what's not
allowed what's acceptable what's not
acceptable you know I think a lot of
people there's the difference between
setting a boundary and keeping a
boundary of course there will be people
who cross our boundaries and then we
have to figure out how we want to you
know navigate that conversation or what
we want to do about that relationship
but yeah this is absolutely about where
we draw that line for ourselves and
drawing that line for ourselves is
particularly challenging
um when we have unresolved wounds and
you know I I laugh I'm going to tell a
little bit of a story here to try to
make this make a lot of sense
I was a boundaryless human for a very
long time
and if I journeyed back to my childhood
um I know the origins of this I uh when
my parents were crashing and burning
around me the way in which I decided to
navigate through life was by pretending
like I was fine not I didn't want to add
anything more to the table I was like
they're crashing and burning there's no
more room for me to not be okay
and so I got very good at all of the
things that I wanted to do and just from
the outside looking in I was a very well
adjusted handling it so well little girl
and yeah like succeeding and
I share often that I would always if you
asked me how I was doing I was fine I'm
good I'm unaffected all good all good
all good you would hear that from me so
this little girl who is a needless
little girl
um
an unaffected little girl became a
needless woman an unaffected I'm fine
woman and
how that would show up in relationships
was I presented as the cool girl you
know I was like I'm down for anything
whatever you want to do absolutely sure
I'm fine I'm unaffected by this and
that's really tied to my relationship
with boundaries I was afraid that you
know I I never knew that not being okay
that there was room for me to not be
okay the fear perception fully
recognized that right like I don't I I
don't necessarily even believe that it
was true about my childhood like I think
that there probably was room for me to
not be okay but that just wasn't my
experience right and that's really
important because this isn't about what
is true or untrue right this is how I
internalized what was happening around
me and how I chose to exist in the world
and then the work that I needed to do to
shift that and so
in adult relationships I also did not
believe that there was room for me to
not be okay I was afraid that if I
wasn't okay with something that a
relationship would end uh this was tied
to a worthiness wound that I learned
um you know with my dad bless him I was
like he's like how much am I in the book
and I was like Dad you're in the
introduction and then you're also in the
worthiness chapter and he goes oh
worthiness and I'm like no no dad not in
a good way in the conditional love kind
of way and he's like oh that's always
interesting when we have to like you and
I both being like in the public eye to
some degree yeah to have to sort of
present these moments to our parents
when they're included in our pain and
it's their it's because of them it's a
it's a tough part of the process but I
always hope that everyone knows myself
my mom my dad their parents everyone
causes pain like it just happens it's
just you're not no one's no one's
special no one's perfect no that's it so
I got a good chuckle every time I talk
about this part of the story but
um you know my dad he when I was a quote
unquote good girl right easy going fine
um he was super helpful super connected
super present super loving when I was a
bit more difficult and challenging I.E
like being a teenager or you know
nothing sort of out of the realm of
reasonable
um I I would get the silent treatment
and cut off sometimes
you know days sometimes weeks and there
was a real punishment that happened
there and I share that part of the story
because it did play into boundaries for
me the lack thereof right having really
porous boundaries because there was such
a fear that unless I was easy going
unless I was fine and unaffected you can
see how all of these parts sort of merge
together and create this perfect moment
of boundarylessness right because it's
like I needed to be fine I needed to be
unaffected and then I learned that when
I was a bit more difficult and
challenging that love and connection and
attachment and presence you know would
be cut off right it like really taught
me not to be honest why understanding
our origin wounds so important to how we
relate to boundaries I know that's the
Focus right now how we relate to
communication how we relate to conflict
right these things play into it and so
you know sometimes they might seem
really obvious so for example if you
grew up in a family system where you
needed to be the pleaser you know then
you might also have poorest boundaries
later on in life because you're just
trying to constantly please people
because successfully pleasing people is
what makes you feel good and worthy and
valuable to the relationships that
you're in having a origin safety wound
for example and you know the safety
chapter is a tough one right because it
includes abuse and we have to we have to
talk about that there but you know you
could see how you know for safety it can
go in a couple of directions where with
that wound you could either be you know
super rigid with high walls up because
people are unsafe and uh this is the
best way for me to protect myself or if
safety was internalized differently
maybe safety is about how quickly I can
connect with someone and make sure that
a relationship
um stays and a codependency then
certainly yeah right and so it's like
that's what's so fascinating to me about
the wounds like it's not black and white
it's such a nuanced conversation and the
same thing could have happened to me and
you but the way that we internalize it
will will it's endless right and so how
we identify with those wounds can be can
be so different right and so yeah I mean
coming back to that boundaries
conversation right it's like I when I
started to realize how I had
maintain this role from childhood into
my adult relationships I remember having
this moment where it again sort of this
profound simple yet profound moment and
aha you know where I was like oh my gosh
I keep saying I'm okay in a particular
relationship when a boundary is being
crossed in like the most wild of ways
and
I'm actually not okay with this my Palms
were sweating my heart was racing
I was like oh my gosh you know I could
barely speak and I remember calling
um my partner at the time uh who was
contemplating going back to an ex of his
and they were talking and spending time
together and all of this stuff
um and at the time I was oh it's okay
it's fine whatever you need to do I get
it I understand this must be so hard for
you you know this therapist in me all
right
um there's context you know it's like
there were so many excuses for it and
when I finally I was having a
conversation with a friend and I finally
came into myself for a moment like how
do you feel you know simple question how
do you feel I was like this is so
disrespectful this is so not okay I
remember calling and saying that and and
ending it
um
even though he was in contemplation
still ending it never spoke to him after
that again and I always describe this as
you know for anybody who's ever done
cross-country skiing and you have the
tracks in the snow it's easier there
right than yeah right and this was a
moment where I jumped off the tracks and
I made a new one and it was hard as hell
right it's like it was thick it was deep
snow but I was like I I'm doing it I'm
doing it I'm changing the role that I
have held and carried from childhood
into my adult relationships I am
speaking
for the first time like almost like a
truth in a romantic relationship that
was so scary for me and I knew it was
ending right I was choosing for it to
end so I knew what the outcome was going
to be but it changed
my
it opened up my vocal cords and my
husband Connor laughs because he's like
I definitely do not know that woman
he's like you have no problems now and I
think it's like when you do it
differently For the First Time new
pattern you're just like I survived this
I can do this this is the way that I
want to live right and you know we have
such a say when it comes to boundaries
but when we struggle to keep and
maintain the boundaries it's because An
Origin wound is activated and there is a
fear there because why think about it
why don't we maintain a boundary that we
say we want to keep right it's like
there is a fear there that someone's
going to get upset with us that
somebody's going to break up with us
that someone's getting worse right I
think it's gonna be worse you're like
well no that's going to be worse than if
I just say okay yeah yeah so again even
like going back to you know what you
were talking about in theory versus in
practice
you know it's like this
it's hard stuff because
when we're in it we want to move away
from the things that scare us that are
going to support the story that we've
held but there's something so powerful
to going back into the origin wounds to
resolve that so when the boundary is
there or being crossed it's not as hard
to uphold it right because the more time
we tend to I am actually worthy I do
actually belong I am a priority right
when we tend to those things right then
in the moment when we go back on our
word when we go back on the boundary
that we say we want to hold like we're
more likely to keep it when we don't
have to work so hard in believing that
we are still worthy even if it means
that the relationship ends or a person
is upset with us or you know we're not a
priority to them something like that
right yeah yeah and it feels like for me
because it's going to play right into
the next one too which is basically
about the lesson and not letting someone
off the hook when they've crossed a
boundary or set or done something that
you don't agree with and to not let them
off the hook because if you otherwise
you're out of Integrity that was the
lesson like you need to have integrity
for your truth and to not let people off
the hook meaning the conversations had
and it's like oh well
um you know they want some kind of
validation or comfort and then when you
go in and save them right this is what
it felt like for me when I go in and
save them by like okay yeah you know
what of course you're amazing like
you're right like whatever whatever that
situation may be
soon as you do that by saving them you
have now abandoned yourself again and
this connection with your inner child or
your higher you know your over Soul or
your you know higher self whatever that
may be whatever you want to call it
um you're not strengthening that
relationship you're you're you're
continuing like there's you're breaking
it up and you don't know yourself as
well when you get out of Integrity so
talk a little bit about what that means
because I actually found I that was one
of them that we we I became very early
in our work where
um I thought it was going to be very
hard to catch the moments because I just
didn't know if I'd be able to identify
it but it happened like twice really
soon and I upheld my boundary and you
know what it it like it was like kind of
like when you turn off the tracks and
you go a new Direction like you're just
on it now like I just got it and then it
continued to strengthen this bond with
myself and my boundaries and my
integrity and who I really was and what
I really stood for by staying in
Integrity so explain what it means to
not let people off the hook so that you
stay in Integrity what you were
describing is not
rupturing the trust with yourself right
because every time you know we say we're
going to do something and we don't and
even though there's a reason for it and
there's a fear and all that like we are
teaching ourselves that we can't trust
ourselves and that that follow through
when we can strengthen that muscle right
that's it's it's it's vital it's vital
it's um
when we hold other people accountable
right when we don't let other people off
the hook
I think sometimes people like hear them
they're like they don't want to be mean
you know they're like
um and I think it's very important right
to be able to hold
accountability and Grace and compassion
for The Human Experience
this is very important piece and I I I
think we can all use a lesson in that
right is like how do I still remember
the context without
making excuses
right without minimizing you know my
experience of something or minimizing
somebody else's right without needing to
give an explanation for something and
you know minimizing or distorting the
impact of something and so you know this
is a it almost feels like an art form
right of like how do I
stand firm in honoring what my
experience is I don't need to annihilate
you I don't need to rip you apart this
isn't what that is I don't need to sit
here and point fingers and blame and
this and that but I also don't need to
make excuses avoid uh shy away from
Focus so much on the context which is
you know one of the things that I did
for so long and again as a therapist
it's like oh this is all I do it all the
time right I'm like context context
context it's like that's we need that
but to not overplay that because we get
washed away our experience gets washed
away when we don't say I'm hurt or that
affected me or I didn't feel good when
you said those words or you know
whatever it might be and listen that
brings us face to face with you know it
could be a few year of Confrontation it
could be a fear of conflict it could be
a fear of you know
a relationship ending yeah right I mean
it's like there are endless things and
again it's like why going back into our
story is so important because if we have
a fear of conflict because we grew up in
a family system where conflict meant
abuse or conflict meant you know the
silent treatment for weeks on end or you
know something like that then we could
exist in relationships avoiding that
trying to create safety for ourselves by
taking a path of opposition and being
non-confrontational at all but in that
we lose that space right this beautiful
space to be able to use our words open
up our voice and be heard and and that's
why I say I sit here because I I don't
want the listener to be like okay you
just have to say what you need to say
and stay in integrity and do this it's
like no no there's layers to this and
there's there's complexity to this
because before you can do that you have
to under understand what keeps you from
doing it one of my favorite I mean this
is the constraint the constraint
question
um that therapists use right instead of
being like why don't you do this we ask
well what keeps you from doing it that
perspective shift is important right
because there are you know when we sit
here and we're like well obviously this
is a good thing to do right anybody
listening to this is like yeah I want to
be in Integrity I want to be able to
trust myself I want people to be able to
hear what it is that I'm feeling right
like all sounds nice but I can't do that
okay why can't I what keeps me from
doing it when we start to answer that
question right that's going to point us
again in the direction of what needs to
be healed what needs our attention what
needs resolution so that I can start to
step into this direction of being able
to hold another person accountable
really hold myself accountable in that
space to say hey this is the experience
that I had and I want to share that with
you because I want you to know know the
impact that XYZ had on me but again we
can't you know bulldoze our way into
that we have to understand why
that's so hard for us to do and what it
is that we need to process and resolve
in order to begin to step in that
direction when I talked about
that that boundaries piece with that the
former partner you know one of the
reasons why I could do that was because
I started to identify my origin pain
right where this all birthed I started
to spend time with that I started to
witness it I started to grieve it right
so that I could then move in that
direction you know and so
yeah it's um
it's not always an easy thing to do
especially when we have spent Decades of
Our Lives doing it differently pleasing
people showing up quote unquote
perfectly not being a disrupter
etc et cetera Etc like there's endless
ways in which we have you know existed
in the world to survive I mean these are
all survival tactics when we're young
because we literally need our parents to
survive we can't work we can't drive we
can't reach the stove yet you know we
literally need our parents so the fourth
big big takeaway uh came a little later
but it was um talking about
unconditional love and I just you know
it was just so important to hear you say
that love can be unconditional but
relationships are not yeah so what does
that mean that's a big oof moment it is
yeah we use that language right like oh
I'm in a this is unconditional it's like
right
no love I do believe can be right you
can have an unconditional love for
someone but we must have conditions in
our relationships right we there must be
right because otherwise
people can say well
I can do anything I want to do not that
most people operate this way right but I
can do anything that I want to and then
you need to choose this relationship
anyway no
no There Are Rules there are
expectations there are agreements spoken
ones ideally right that we have and you
know I can love someone of course but
choose not to be in relationship with
them if they're the way that they show
up the way that they talk to me the way
that they treat me doesn't match with
what is workable for me in that chapter
of my life we've all heard oh love is
unconditional relationships are
unconditional it's like that message was
such a it felt like such a dangerous one
right because it it almost forced people
to
um have to bypass their experiences and
their feelings and be okay or like find
a way to be okay with things and I I
think this is such a healthy way to
exist in the world right that like yeah
to find what the conditions are what I'm
able what what we want to create out of
this relationship together what we are
and listen like it can ebb and flow and
it can move a bit like we can have an
expectation
um if you're in a monogamous
relationship for example that we're not
going to cheat on each other okay right
then that could shift because someone
could cheat and that doesn't mean
necessarily right that that relationship
is going to be over uh immediately right
there's a lot of conversation there's a
lot of navigation that could happen in
that space But I think it's you know we
know we we have to check in with each
other over and over and over again to
make sure that the conditions of our
relationships are up to speed
a lot of times couples for example they
have certain expectations or agreements
for the relationship and then they never
check in with each other for the next
five years or ten years you know and
it's like wait like you're the the
Agreements are changing and we need to
be able to communicate about that and
like not updating your will and having
kids and all kinds of different things
it's like no like obviously things have
changed a lot has happened you've got to
keep that stuff up yeah but I think
there's you know there's an empowerment
in that sentence right it's like love
can be unconditional but relationships
cannot right they have to require that
and there's an empowerment there that
says like I don't have to accept
anything yeah I don't have to just sit
here and be like well because I love you
because we agreed to this like anything
can happen here like I'm allowed to have
conditions to being in this relationship
these are the conditions for us to
succeed as friends as partners as this
as that whatever it is and to not have
to be afraid of communicating that and
sharing that and again of course right
like setting the boundaries around that
yeah it could be called unbounded love
too it feels like another word for it
that could replace it but I like to
think of it as like these conditions or
boundaries or or whatever the word you
want to use for it for the relationship
that's not unconditional is like it's
supposed to help you know how to love me
right like I'm not gonna make it a
freaking mystery I'm gonna tell you what
you have to do this is the key to the
kingdom right if you can if you can live
if this works for you great if it
doesn't fine we all should move on but
that's like unbounded unconditional love
is is not that helpful because it's
impossible to imagine that we don't have
triggers and we don't have wounds and we
don't have things we're working through
and like you said sometimes we're more
sensitive sometimes we're less sensitive
we just don't navigate life like a
Buddha you know we navigate life being
triggered and unless we tell our partner
or the people that are close to us what
those landmines are and what the and
what it makes us comfortable and feel
safe like how can they be expected to do
a good job it's like giving in it's like
giving a pilot an airplane and no lesson
it's like we're gonna crash yeah they're
gonna Crash and Burn you know I think
it's like the conditions are actually
what allows a relationship to thrive
yeah right it's like otherwise it can
just be chaos you know that's that's it
is like no no this isn't meant to like
squeeze something right it's meant to to
create create the environment for the
relationship to evolve and Thrive
um and so yeah I love that one too I'm
glad that was a that was one that stood
out to you yeah those those were the
four most translator and I mean look I I
like have those were literally like I
always write my notes like they are
right at the top and I have like
infinitely more questions I was going to
talk to you about of course some of them
got a little bit included but one of
them that I want to ask about because
this feels a little nuanced but and Miss
like Miss like I don't quite have a
grasp as to how to
see this feel this clearly and execute
this
so maybe you can help me
what
does it take to
help someone see you or to see someone
else like people always say and want to
feel seen they want to feel heard like
this is something feels like like a
really deep level maybe not the deepest
level but this is a very deep level that
creates a tremendous connection so is it
something I have to do is it something
someone else has to do is this some
magical connection that you just have to
find the right person and you feel seen
help a girl out help us out yeah I I the
first thing that comes to mind is that
it can be very confronting to see
another
when what is being asked to be seen
requires that person to then see that in
themselves
yeah and it's
that part can be because when one person
is being vulnerable like again we can
listen high level and like yeah okay
thanks for sharing that with me yada
yada right like many people can kind of
go through those motions but I think
when we're talking about being seen
scene you know that like the nuanced
scene
um we are we're talking about uh someone
really deeply connecting to the
experience they're they're being a level
of not that they necessarily walked the
same experiences as you did or
um you know can relate firsthand to that
specific thing but it's there's an
access point that happens when a person
is seeing a deep pain within themselves
that then allows them to see a deep pain
within another and I think when a person
is asking
to have a deep pain of theirs seen by a
partner and that and a partner or a
friend or whomever has not has resisted
consciously unconsciously it doesn't
matter but is resisted or not been able
to see their own deep pain that can be
incredibly challenging I think it's one
of the biggest constraints that I notice
and you know because it's like if I have
to connect to it and see it with you
then there's an access point for me and
sometimes people don't want to want to
go there they don't want to go there
they don't know how to go there it feels
too scary to go there it means that the
idealized you know story of their
childhood or their parent or whomever is
going to get you know shifted slightly
right like all of those things can be a
deterrent in that in that way and so a
lot of times right it's like oh to go
into you know intimacy right
um going inwards seeing my inner World
seeing your in a world having you see my
inner world having you see your inner
world right it's like where the blocks
are for the self there are blocks for
others there have to be right because
otherwise it like it requires something
that you're not ready to meet in
yourself and so it doesn't have to be
the same thing are you saying that if
someone has like a a wound where they
have been abandoned in some way or
someone has a wound where they were
abused in some way physically maybe like
whatever that may be does it have to
mirror itself or is it that someone can
empathize because they've been hurt this
amount or this or or like or no it
doesn't in person yeah no it doesn't
have to be the same okay um no not at
all and it doesn't need to be the same
story in the sense of like oh that's the
reason why I can't see you because
that's too close to mine right I think
to me it's much more about right that
level like the connection to
vulnerability that that fear of like
what this is going to open up and so I
can stay surface level with you right
where I'm like think again like I said
like thank you for sharing and I you
know appreciate you so it's like when
someone shares something that's like
makes them cry or like something that
hurts them like makes them feel very
insecure then you go okay here's
something that makes me really emotional
and something that makes me really feel
insecure and then in they don't have to
be the same at all but they invoke the
same emotion like they give you the same
they it's like it's almost like it it's
like an access point to the amount of
your heart that you're willing to show
them and your truth and you go look I'm
gonna I'm bringing in like I'm gonna
bring in two big bags full here you go
and you bring me your bags full and then
you kind of go okay and and that is what
creates the I feel seen is that you're
willing to be that level of vulnerable
with someone because as another thing
that I like to say is you know trust is
a big thing in a relationship and it's
like yeah I want to trust you but if you
don't give me anything to trust how do
you know I'm trustworthy you know like
you have to give someone somebody
something to be trusted with and so you
do that for each other you kind of go
okay I'm gonna meet you there and that
is the I feel seen I feel heard another
reason where that I've seen is when
now an adult
um who was once a child who
um was a was an emotional support or
caretaker for a parent for example
um where they were in a role that they
should not have been in
um and that parent over shared
um they let that child in on very
intimate details of their life their
feelings right like the child was really
just like kind of a long for the ride
and saw a lot of it that is another
example where I can see sometimes a
person be really closed off or shut down
to seeing feeling alongside of partner
for example
um because
of the very
painful experience and exhaustive
experience of being in a role of
caretaking that emotional experience of
a parent and so uh again right sort of
an unre unresolved stuff right but the
unresolved stuff that blocks a person
from being able to actually open
themselves up connect see hear
understand you know be a partner to
someone in the way if we're prioritizing
intimacy and vulnerability right so you
know a lot of this well I guess I would
say all of this would come from
something that's unresolved right like
why why would I not be able to or want
to see you here you'll understand you
connect to you be intimate vulnerable
with you well because there's something
that's unresolved for me whether it's
you know an example like I just gave of
a child who had to be you know the
emotional caregiver
um of a parent to someone who has a part
of their story and their own pain that
they have yet to touch and be able to
resolve themselves right and so yeah you
think it's like again what is that
constraint to being able to connect with
you and I think it's why you know for
for therapists especially you know no
surprise that most therapists get into
this work to resolve their own stuff
right oh my God but it's like well you
know you're preaching the choir I try
and tell people when they get mad if a
guru or a therapist or someone that's
supposed to be an expert in a field is
having a struggle it's like why the hell
do you think that they got into this
field it's like right you usually become
an expert in something because you need
it they're pissed balance the science
and the art form and I think there's you
know the more truly right like the more
integrated the more resolved we are
right like we can hold that space in a
very different way and you know you have
therapists in any profession right who
are like very skilled you know
moderately skilled et cetera et cetera
right and it's like but but all of this
right to see clients right to be able to
feel to deeply connect to have that
other person on the other side or in the
room or what you know whatever the
scenario is now uh postcovid right it's
like that so much of that right what the
other person feels like no no she really
like I feel deeply seen by this person
right is has a lot to do with our own
resolution right
right and listen it's a skill set
certainly right there's an art form to
this practice right there really is but
there is a need right like there's so
many people who are not doing that
resolution work there's going to be a
disconnect there right and so yeah and I
think you're talking probably more about
you know intimate partnership or
um
relationship of like okay how can
somebody really see and feel and connect
it's the same thing though with whomever
okay it's like the more resolved a
person is the more able they are to
deeply see feel connect and understand
the more connected you are to yourself
the more you can connect with others
yeah it's a mirror relationships are a
big
yeah and it's listen it's a cliche for a
reason like it's real you know it's like
it's absolutely true what are some signs
for people that are sort of walking
through their life that
um
that they can look for that are
hopefully as simple as possible because
these things are just so hard to see
like it's almost like it takes like a
rock bottom or a like a really big event
to get you into it so like let's save
people from that like what is it that
they should look for to get them to go
okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna I'm gonna
take a Next Step here to excavate myself
um like what what could be happening in
their life that would be good signs that
they should do a little bit of work
because look there are some unicorns out
there I'm sure that end up in this whole
um uh secure securely attached
relationship category I've never met one
I don't know one but uh but usually we
fall into the you know we fall into one
of these origin wounds we fall into an
anxious attachment or an avoidant and
you know it creates a lot of problems so
what are some big signs that you could
do some work okay number one think about
the last time you were really reactive
reactivity is a direct line into it it
points the arrow and you know when we
have listen we're reactive for good
reasons you know but boundaries being
acrossed were hurt by something
um here's the pattern again right like
react reactivity is beautiful important
information so if you can think back to
the last time you were reactive or the
things that make you the most reactive
spend time there because they're going
to point an arrow to something that's
unresolved oh yeah what's a good prompt
for that you're great with problems
there's a lot of prompts in the book so
what's a good prompt that people could
go like right now sit down and write
yeah like the thing that makes me most
reactive is person I am most reactive
with is I react when they right so just
a few there just to like get going right
of just like yeah who's who who gets
under my skin right what's this thing
right is it something they do is it a
look that they give is it is it the
words that they speak is it the words
that they don't speak right like what's
the thing that just gets me going and
revs my engine right because it's there
that's gonna be like yeah it's that damn
look that you give that makes me feel
looked over unimportant like you could
give two shits about me or you know and
it's like or it's the thing that you do
where I'm just like I've asked you so
many times and you will not prioritize
what I've asked you to do oh okay boom
there it is let's explore that further
right so yeah reactivity so important
big line
um in the same vein if there is a time
where you are reflecting and you're like
wow I blew that thing out of proportion
again in the same vein as reactivity but
that is a that's a pretty good indicator
too where you're like whoa that didn't
seem to match what just played out I
have to look at that a little bit closer
overreaction is a good indicator yeah it
is and listen sometimes it's hard to you
know be reflective on that where you're
like oh yeah that was like bigger than
it maybe needed to be but you know again
it's it's in response to something right
that's what's so beautiful about our our
systems like they're responding to
something appropriately it might not be
this particular moment right but it's
responding to something that the system
is experiencing appropriately so we
don't have to shame ourselves we don't
have to get upset with ourselves we just
have to get curious and bring that
inquiry forward to see like oh okay I
need to like dig around here and see
what needs my intention
um I love the like you know when you can
give the advice to everyone else but you
can't take it yourself
why are you saying I'm not calling you
out
I would like to be a therapist
well second career okay it's coming oh
no I just do it on the side yeah you're
like no this is this is for the real the
real problem is is when it's in a
relationship and I go can I
psychoanalyze you right now and they go
[__] no you can't
stay out and you're like listen it's
happening I'm like what happens now too
yeah
um so for so many of us right the like
I'm able to give this advice to everyone
else and you know but when it comes to
me doing it there's a big struggle there
so
for example
your friend has a I don't know like an
interview for a job and you're like go
in there confidently you know you start
like kind of preaching and giving that
advice but when it comes to you having
the job interview you are not confident
you're struggling with things you're the
self-critic is Super Active did it you
know all this stuff and it's like bam
there it is right like there's something
that needs to be resolved there and
there's a wound there for you right if
if the thing that you're telling
everybody else to do is not something
that you can do fairly easily right then
there's an inquiry there I know the
wrinkle of the nose is like oh what's to
look at
unwanted patterns right it's like we all
have them we're like we get into the
same fight with the person over and over
and over again or you lose track of what
you're even fighting about but it's the
same thing going on and on and on or you
get hooked I always I use that language
but it like it kind of feels that way
we're like I'm not I promise I go in
with good intentions and then bam like
I'm back like engaging in a conversation
that I know I don't want to have with
this person but I couldn't help myself
and I just needed to prove my point or
get my point across or something like
that
um obviously patterns are endless
there's so many examples I keep choosing
unavailable emotionally unavailable
people who I continue talking about me
again et cetera et cetera you're like no
no no no
um and so you know again but those are
the things those are the arrows that are
like okay with our our behavior is
pointing us to something right these
patterns that were like I don't want to
keep doing this never again right people
Proclaim I will never do this thing
again right and like we mean it we mean
it when we say it but then we find
ourselves back in the familiar and okay
things will remain familiar like that
until there is more resolution
grieving witnessing you know eventually
making that pivot
um and so yeah those unwanted patterns
in our adult life are another great
example of yeah just like a quick bam
like okay what's The Unwanted pattern
that I have in my life there it is okay
I need to examine that more so those are
some good examples of just like quick
signs you know like the neon sign it's
just flashing there look for the
reactivity look for
um the patterns look for the advice you
give but you can't take look for the
things that don't match and are blown
out of proportion right like look for
those things and just yeah get curious
about what wound it could be pointing to
recently talking to men about this sort
of masculine feminine balance and I
think it'd be great to ask you what does
it I've been asking a lot of guys like I
asked your husband Connor about you know
a healthy masculine a healthy a healthy
feminine energy like what does a healthy
feminine and math masculine energy
within a woman look like
you know the the feminine and the way
it's often described is like the flow
it's it's the it's the life force you
know it's the it's the playfulness
um we always laugh when it's like yeah
the feminine is life and the masculine
is death
um but you know it's like no it's it's
I'm gonna use this language because I
think it it ties this all together is
that
to when we
resolve
a lot of our pain in our wounds or we're
on we're in that practice of it right
not the sense of completion but when we
are resolving those things we're
touching them we're we're in
conversation with them I really believe
it's when those
um like the light traits get to come
forward
so you know the Vigilant masculine
energy to protect you right right starts
to dissolve exactly right and that's
what's going to say like you know we've
got lists like the the shadow masculine
and the shadow feminine and the light
masculine and the light feminine it's
like I just want to tie this all
together because you know yeah like the
hyper vigilance the you know the
aggression the this like it's the more
that we resolve the more
anyone right can steps into the light
right so it's like the more I can step
into my playfulness for example the more
I can step into my flow the more I can
step into my ease the more I can put
down the like go go go go go and
production and you know like winning and
this and it's it's so funny right
because you win anyway you know you
produce anyway like it all just it all
happens but the drive is not coming from
the pain right the drive is coming from
the resolution oh my gosh like I I
actually I feel that I'm saying that
where I'm like yeah that's it right is
like
life comes from the resolution it
doesn't come from the pain right living
doesn't come from the pain I often say
that our pain are wounds and our gifts
are really close to one another like are
so many of our gifts birth from our pain
there's a point in life where we can we
don't need to be motivated by the pain
with the gifts anymore like a lot of
times people are so afraid to resolve
the pain because they feel like they're
going to lose the gift and you know it's
like whatever it is exactly right the
edge that's it we're talking about that
yeah you will not lose the edge just
because you resolve things right your
gift gets to remain it just gets to be
driven by your healing instead and so
you know back to your question like men
women masculine feminine energies that
we all hold right is like
the goal is to resolve as much as
possible so that you get to be in the
light with all of those traits
characteristics qualities that exist on
those lists right and the to be driven
by the healing it is a PR I promise you
it is a better existence and I promise
you that you will not lose the
incredible things that you have gained
from your story so many people say well
I wouldn't be who I am without the pain
without the story I'm like you're right
absolutely right I wouldn't be me you
wouldn't be you and every single
listener wouldn't be who they are today
without the story and I thought well I
wouldn't go back and change the story
it's like yeah yeah we get caught in
this space of like so I'm just gonna
like thank you for the pain you know
it's like like listen it's played out
we're here yeah that was my story you've
got your story and now it's time to
resolve and I can be I can acknowledge
and be grateful for the gifts that I am
now using in this world that are
motivated and coming from a healing
place right but I don't need to be
grateful for the pain the abuse the this
the that the things that I witnessed I
don't have to be grateful for that I can
acknowledge that that's my story I can
see what birthed from it right I can
hold on to these gifts that I have that
came from that specific story that
needed to happen the way that it did in
order for me to unfold into this human I
am today but I don't need to sit here
and protect a story or diminish it or
minimize it or validate it in some weird
way or you know protect it or
rationalize it or intellectualize it
right like the main part like a big part
of what I try to say in the book is like
we have have to call our story the story
you know we have to name the things the
things and if we tamper with it at all
we tamper with our healing right if we
have to say oh but it all happened for
like good reason you know it's like no
that takes away from us being able to
connect to the actual pain and the
actual wounds so I know I moved away
from your question but I got on a I got
a little good you're good that's that's
the flow I mean the flow it feels so
much like maybe and I've I'm not going
to go into detail why I all the reasons
why I think this but it's like the
masculine is kind of like the thing you
want or like the aspiration or the goal
and then the feminine goes let's go and
just like like flows with it and allows
whatever to come through to come through
because we think we always know the best
way for things to happen but when the
Universe goes ahead and lines it up for
us it happens in ways that we could
never orchestrate ourselves and then you
go oh wow yeah that's pretty great like
what if I just you know I need to be in
that space more often what do you think
is the um you know again on this sort of
topic of masculinity and femininity
there's so I feel like there's so many
men that are confused and I feel like
there's
um
and rightfully so I think at this point
in time but also
um you know there's like a resistance to
the word patriarchy and
um but maybe maybe just highlighting
what could come more into balance for
men and for women men
grew up the men we know
um in some ways maybe it's shifting a
little bit now but you know men grew up
very conditioned to not feel you know
it's no surprise right not feel not be
connected to emotion
um not be vulnerable the emotion that
they were able to express or connect to
is anger which often comes out as you
know aggression
um and you know there's a lot of
you know I I think one of the things I
hear from men a lot is like you know I
guess if they're if they're dating women
women want us to be vulnerable but then
when we're vulnerable they
see that as either a weakness or they
see that as a turn off or like they
don't know how to be with it and you
know I think there's also there's just a
like there's a lot of
war on men who were on like that that's
going on there's a lot of hatred
um and
towards anybody who is such a not just
directed a lot of identity politics
going on there's a lot of victimization
going on there are a lot of problems but
there's a lot of drama around it too
yeah and I I remember seeing a post
um where a person a therapist had posted
some statistics about
um men and suicide and
um there were endless comments in that
Instagram post of uh presumably women
um saying like the job's not done until
they all kill themselves or the like I
mean it was beyond it was beyond and
that hurts me to see
um
there's so much anger and you know the
collective ear resolution I've used the
word unresolved probably like a hundred
times today but to think about like the
ear resolution that is the collective
your resolution that makes us hate each
other that makes us not find a way to
come together and hold again that
context right which does hold
accountability
um with Grace and compassion I would say
to your question I wish that more people
could hold that balance to your question
what do I think we need to be doing you
know it's like we need to be able to
hold accountability with Grace and
compassion for ourselves and with others
it's not an excuse obviously there are
plenty of people in history in the world
today who abuse their power who
um you know behave in atrocious ways
absolutely
um but we
we use broad Strokes instead of calling
out specific people you know we we use
the irresolution right on the the
collective scale and we stay in
just this
angry and hateful place and that's a
disconnector always always will be right
there's no Bridge there and so
yeah I mean that's my wish you know is
that we can be reminded it's funny I'll
tie it like there's a part right at the
end of the book I talk about
um something that Michael Kerr says
which is
think of your mother
as your grandmother's daughter
and see the perspective that shifts oh
yeah I totally it feels similar to like
yes my inner child and know that my mom
was a daughter and my you know like just
everybody was just a
yeah you know I'm a I'm an a newish
mother
um I have a 21 month old and you know
when you are close to a little human
like that you know as a little boy
um
you know like that's the that's the
that's the reminder right it's like that
person you hate or that Collective group
of humans that you hate it's like we
have lost the story yeah you know we've
lost the story we've lost the reminder
that we're all wounded you know and
again not an excuse right plenty of
people who have abused power or you know
like exist in the world in a really
awful awful way absolutely right but to
be able to balance that feels so
important to me and you know when you're
around
the babies and you're like that's we all
yeah we all started there every single
one of us and there was a big Grand deep
story right and like
we could all just get to know these
stories a little bit more a little bit
more a little bit more and you know at
the very minimum right if we can start
to get to know our story a little bit
more if I can start to get to know my
partner story a little bit more my
friend's story a little bit more my
parents story a little bit more my
sibling story a little bit more how many
relational situations are we in where we
don't actually know how our mom was
treated growing up we don't actually
know what happened with our dad's dad
like we don't actually you know we don't
hear any stories you know it's crazy
okay well
um that's such it's such a good point
um maybe we could finish off here with
just
um uh kind of giving people some insight
if people said yes to growth like if
people are like hey like I'm ready like
where are where are all those ways that
you can like what are the best ways to
grow and also what are the best access
points meaning like a child a
relationship a dog a mom like where are
those like hot buttons because I feel
like I just you know you know me I'm
always talking about relationships
because everything else I just like I'm
cool with but like you know people get
into relationships and they get mad if
they get you know if they get upset it's
like dude it's meant to bring out all
the [__] like relationships are like you
want to grow stay in you know
um so like where are the places where
people can go I'm willing to stand in
the fire and then what are the tools
when you're in the fire to go okay I'm
gonna get through and and that what is
that path
well certainly like intimate
relationships are the greatest I love
that you started with kids like have a
baby yeah right I'm sure yeah like maybe
don't jump in right there but
um LOL it happens sometimes of course
but it is wow the mirror is it's big but
any intimate relationship is gonna do
that for you certainly
um
initiatory experiences right so like you
know
pushing your Edge a bit you know I think
there's something that happens when it's
like you you like cross that line of oh
this is really cozy and comfy for me but
when you kind of pass that threshold
right I think we meet parts of ourselves
and I'm sure you had experiences like
this when you were when you were driving
to getting to the place where there's
the darkness
um where you come into contact with the
darkness you know like there is you're
gonna grow quite a bit
easier I I was listening to
do you know who David Goggins is oh yeah
he's like people think it's masochistic
but it's not for me it's like I don't
grow in the light right I only grow from
the dark and so I I exist there I want
to stay there because that's the way
that I grow and evolve my suggestion is
not to go to Coggin style but
um you know there is something to you
know whether you do that work with a
therapist
um whether you do that in a retreat
group setting I've Loved they're some of
my most favorite experiences of life
right is running Retreats and having you
know 12 strangers come and do deep deep
work and seeing the impact of strangers
witnessing one another and like I said
before it's like I don't need the person
who put the wound there in the first
place to be the person who witnesses it
right sometimes it's a stranger
sometimes it's someone you've known for
24 hours who's there and so you know
Finding clinicians or finding
practitioners who you respect who you
trust right like getting to know their
work a little bit and maybe going to
work with those people obviously as a
therapist I'm always mindful of like do
I you know do I support this do I not
but I think that there are obviously
there's a lot of um you know psychedelic
treatment
um that is that is coming into
therapeutic practice
um legal some places not legal other
places very mindful again of that but
you know and know plenty of people who
have had such incredible experiences
um in a therapeutic environment you know
where it's deeply deeply deeply deeply
healing and of course right like again
you're meeting yourself in a very
different way in an experience like that
um when you're in it it's not linear
you've probably heard it before
um but just the reminder okay that this
is a dance you do sometimes take a
couple steps forward and then many many
steps back and sometimes you you know
move or the lesson has to come back
again in different form in different
shape and different size but having good
people in your life to support you in
that space so that you're not walking
the path by yourself like sometimes we
do have to take the walk on our own with
certain things right where it's like I
don't need people to hold my hands in
this space but to make sure that your
support is there I think a lot of times
people
you know unfortunately right there are
many people in this world who don't feel
like they have people in their lives
they can turn to and share the most
intimate details with and you know from
I think that's one of the most important
things when you're walking this path is
to become a part of something whether
that means joining a men's group or
women's group or whatever like even if
it's a virtual group like but that there
is a community for you to feel supported
a community where people can reflect
things back to you or continue to
process with you
um you know to open up with at least one
person to let them know you know what it
is that you are navigating through if
you don't have a partner or if you you
know if you don't have
um you know a family member you would
you would share that with and so saying
the words out loud is so powerful I mean
you see it all day every day in your
work but when somebody has to say the
words out loud it's just like it unlocks
the emotion and helps it flow through
you yeah and just that like no matter
how hard it is like even though you
can't see it in the moment sometimes
right that like the the the dots don't
make sense or they're not all connecting
it's like to trust uh you know again I
know it's like one of those things like
oh my god I've heard it so many times
but there is something to trusting the
process truly right that like this
process is going to lead you somewhere
keep going pause if you need to take
breaks when you need to certainly right
like I've had plenty of people who are
like take a break from therapy and then
you know a year later poke back up you
know it's like yeah that's it right like
pause when you need to take a break go
out into the world do the thing see what
it's like right and then sort of
re-enter back into the space when you
need more support so yeah just again
Grace compassion with the self As you
move through it gentleness and awareness
that yeah like
it can shift the way that you see the
world and see people and the way that
you've held them
um and so sometimes it can feel a bit
destabilizing
um but with proper support and good
alignment with the people you choose to
be a part of that support system
there's some beautiful stuff in there it
really is yeah it really is
well thank you for sharing that
beautiful stuff and helping people step
into a reality that's more peaceful and
more joyful it does not mean they're
excluded from Pain it does not mean
that's not part of life but I always
think that the work
the reason for the work is because I
want to be happier more of the time and
I also want to reach higher levels of
Joy yeah like I want to be able to like
some my heart breaks open to the pain it
breaks open equal and opposite to the
joy and like the more we can give
ourselves permission to just go into
deeper spaces the more we open our heart
up it's kind of like that vulnerability
game of like oh how far are you gonna go
okay I'll meet you there yeah thank you
that's a good point it's such a good
point I think brene Brown I said it
maybe in a TED Talk
um like you can't pick and choose which
feelings you turn down and up right
right so it's like when you turn the
dial down you turn it down and all of
them let me turn it up you turn it up on
all of them and I love I think you just
you know you said it there it's like
yeah you're gonna feel the sadness but
then you're also going to feel the joy
and yeah like it's a decision
um again sometimes we need our hand to
be held but a decision to to turn up the
feelings and to step into that so
there's the hand I know congratulations
I'm so proud of you I know how hard you
work I know I remember the moments when
you're like okay I'm deep in book stuff
we you know we we need to do we need to
take a break from therapy now and you're
working so hard so I'm just like so
proud of you I I've never written a book
but I have had a couple books and I just
know like even from my side it's a lot
of work so
um congratulations and I can't wait to
you know just witness the world as we
move forward and having people like you
share this information and people
healing thank you I appreciate you yeah
miss you dear yes right back
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button